[Applauso]
sono un viaggiatore ma in quel momento
della mia vita io mi ero completamente
perso
e vorrei iniziare questo racconto con
voi da un'immagine e avrei bisogno
subito la vostra collaborazione queste
sono due piante non è così allora per
alzata di mano chi dice che la pianta
migliore delle due è la numero 1 fatevi
vedere
avete appena preso il caffè fatevi
vedere quelle
grazie chi dice per alzata di mano che
la pianta migliore è la numero 2
abbiamo un sacco di astenuti oggi
andiamo avanti quell'immagine
qualcuno ha cambiato idea
di fatto questa immagine all'epoca
abbiamo fatto venire in mente due cose
la prima le persone vedono solo ciò che
c'è in superficie non riescono a vedere
in profondità ciò che ci sta sotto la
seconda è sotto in profondità che
avviene la trasformazione e dove
possiamo creare dei frutti più grandi
certo sotto c'è buio e il buio ci
spaventa ma nel buio che accade la magia
in quel momento nella vita vivevo reggio
emilia la mia città natale
era il 2010 e ero in carriera si suol
dire nell'ambito delle vendite
nell'ambito informatico lavoravo con
aziende multinazionali e nazionali e
tutti i tipi e era arrivato da ricoprire
una posizione molto importante ben
pagata con un sacco di benefit ero
giovane ero single casa ideale per gli
altri ero quella fogliolina la grande
per me questo buio
in quel momento mia vita era buio nero
c'era solo un barlume di luce che non
capivo subito dove venire ma quel buio
ho capito perché ero imprigionato nelle
mie gabbie mentali cioè tutto ciò che
avevo era reale ma avevo tutto è saperlo
e sentivo di non avere niente ero triste
ero infelice
non sapevo come fare
mi ricordo però non avevo gli strumenti
che oggi grazie al mio lavoro all'epoca
ma non sapevo come fare vi ricordo
quella luce dico caspita con la luce è
dentro di te quella luce sei tu quella
luce ciascuno di noi e allora dico devi
ripartire da te da te stesso perché lì
dentro che avviene la magia non è così e
allora ero impaurito non stavo bene e ho
deciso di partire per un viaggio ma
immaginate un momento una persona che ha
bisogno di sicurezza prevedibilità
certezza era bloccata delle sue
abitudini ero spaventato e deciso di
prendere un volo per il sud america da
solo e tre settimane zain spalla senza
destinazione ero terrorizzato
non volevo partire poi per fortuna
alcuni amici e non solo intorno a me mi
hanno sostenuto e uno mi ha detto una
cosa incredibile mi ha detto federico
ricordati in viaggio tutto funziona in
viaggio tutto funziona io me lo ripetevo
in viaggio tutto funziona sono partito
non con poche difficoltà e inizialmente
il mio viaggio non funzionava nulla
nulla non ho dormito quattro notti
consecutive ea me non era mai capitato
ero stremato tremavo mi ricordo che
taglia i un pezzo di pane col coltello
mi sono tagliato una mano non è normale
volevo tornare a casa ma a casa stava
male
quindi che fare
sono qui per cambiare vado avanti non mi
fermo continuo e così è stato sono
andato avanti e piano piano e il viaggio
le cose ingranavano conoscevo persone
vedevo posti incredibili esperienze e
tutto ciò migliorava di giorno in giorno
fino a quando non mi rompo un piede
classico o meglio non credo in quel
momento molti mi hanno chiesto quindi
torni a casa no perché quel piede era
simbolico quella rottura era simbolica
in cui il momento rotto le mie gabbie
mentali
mi ero liberato ero tornato me stesso mi
ero riscoperto e stavo bene così bene
che volavo in alto e detto ora sono
libero di volare in alto
finalmente ho riscoperto il mio
potenziale chi sono
quello che ha creato quello che c'è
finora che non vedevo più quindi torno a
casa e dico bene ora inizia un nuovo
viaggio
e i nuovi aggio qual è la tua direzione
federico non vuoi più quel che hai ma
dove vuoi andare ed è caspita sapevo che
ero bravo ottenere risultati mi venivano
bene e facilmente e vivevo la mia
giornata il mio lavoro
felicemente e le vedevo intorno a me a
tante persone che non erano molto felici
anzi un po in cacchiate e che facevano
fatica a raggiungere risultati e ho
detto caspita gli devo aiutare
voglio aiutare le persone a trasformare
i loro risultati le loro qualità di vita
e ma come
era 2011
un giorno quando decidi le cose poi
accadono delle cose un giorno mi
chiamano amica mi dice senti vado a
parlare con una persona perché ho
bisogno di ri orientarmi un po wow
fantastico vengo con te
sento che c'è qualcosa per me ascolto
questo colloquio alla fine faccio una
domanda come si fa a fare il suo
mestiere come si fa a diventare un
mental coach
in un epoca oggi mentre coach graziano
in piedi tutti lo conoscono non è così
ma nel 2011 e vi sfido
di fatto ho iniziato un percorso di
formazione e ho detto federico ora tu
devi ripartire a riseminare sei un nuovo
seme
devi ricominciare daccapo tutto da zero
perché quello che vuoi
e il seme che ti chiama il tuo nonnino
altro ma il tuo sì quindi dai e allora
iniziato mi sono formato quando mi sono
stato è pronto
abitavo con i miei genitori all'epoca
vado rari dico allora ho deciso di dare
dimissioni da un posto sicuro e ben
pagato per aprire partita iva è un
mestiere sconosciuto
ora non è quello che ho detto loro ma è
quello che loro hanno capito e contava
quello lo imparai dopo di fatto inizio
questo nuovo viaggio è di nuovo non
funziona una mazza
e poi vedete io no
e in quel momento
avevo speso moltissimi soldi per
formarmi e ringrazio di aver speso in
quel momento
ora ma non in quel momento o
vedevo che i soldi non entravano più e
uscivano e iniziava una crisi
finanziaria
in più il lavoro non ingranava come
pensavo di fatto poi quello che è
successo è successo una cosa strana mi
sono iniziate ad arrivare a dei pensieri
strani del tipo e se ti fossi sbagliato
so se mi sono mai risuonati delle cose
di questo tipo e se avessero avuto
ragione gli altri e se non ce la fai e
se fallisci ecco in quel momento
rispetto al viaggio precedente però
avevo studiato gli strumenti mentali e
ho capito una cosa quella roba lì si
chiama dialogo interiore
avete presente la voce che parla dentro
di voi ecco proprio quella che vi sta
dicendo ora ma quale voce e lei la vita
identificata l'avete trovata anche voi
in quel momento ho capito che la mente
se non la governi mentre
e ti tira indietro
rispetto dove vuoi andare e lo fa per
proteggerti pertinenti al suo con frison
manente e quindi se invece ha gli
strumenti per governarla 16 ei cc vieni
con me
si può dire ti accompagno aiutami
aiutiamoci e diventa più grande
acceleratore di risultati che possiamo
avere nel nostro potenziale interno
questo viaggio in noi l'ho fatto da solo
è tuttora sono in viaggio scrittore al
viaggio non l'ho fatto da solo ma l'ho
fatto insieme a molte persone che non mi
tiravano indietro ma mi spingevano o
metteremo davanti mi supportavano queste
persone richiamo il gruppo dei pari
sono persone che ama amici familiari
imprenditori manager che ti aiutano e ti
supportano e che vogliono il tuo bene a
prescindere da quello che loro pensano
sia il bene per te
questo è un passaggio importante
e di fatto mi sono circondato di queste
persone due sono qui oggi tra l'altro è
una delle quali l'ho conosciuta tre mesi
dopo che ho deciso cosa fare di nuovo
quando decidi agisci le cose accadono
questa persona oggi è mia moglie e la
mamma di mia figlia
e tre mesi dopo aver deciso la conosco
proprio qui in val d'orcia
guarda caso no e allora lì erano
fidanzati bisogna decidere dove si va a
vivere io abitavo a reggio emilia vicina
milano quindi nuovo business sono venuto
a petroio trequanda
la capitale del coaching europeo non è
così
di nuovo una scelta controcorrente ma
nella mia direzione ho deciso di
prendere le mie radici di metterla nel
cuore sapendo che poi cuore era ben
nutrito il business e così è stato
di fatto non sono scelte facili ma sono
scelte di direzione e qui ho scelto
questo luogo perché qui mia famiglia non
è un numero è un nome ed un volto è una
persona insieme alla comunità
è cresciuta insieme ad altre persone
acquisirà radici e valori che porterà
con sé e poi dove mettere le sue radici
lo deciderà lei ma le porterà sempre con
sé e questa è la cosa importante per me
di fatto tutto questo è stato molto
impegnativo e tuttora il viaggio
impegnativo ma io li definisco impegno
attivo e chi di voi ha ottenuto
risultati sa di cosa parlo non arrivano
da soli non è così male volte le persone
pensano che basta pensare di volere per
far arrivare le cose no almeno per la
mia esperienza ci vuole un impegno
attivo bisogna andare avanti insieme per
lavorare e ottenere quei risultati e
ancora ecco questo è quello che io ho
imparato in questo in questo piccolo
viaggio vorrei condividerlo con voi io
ho imparato che è fondamentale definire
la propria direzione che siamo una
persona una famiglia un'azienda
un'organizzazione dobbiamo sapere dove
andiamo e non deve essere solo la mia
testa se siamo in più di uno ma dobbiamo
condividere ed essere sicuri che tutti
andiamo in quella direzione se no
andremo da un'altra parte ma non dove
volete voi ea me all'epoca non piacque
prendere la strada che per gli altri era
migliore ma non per me anche se lo
standard voleva così
e ancora
la mente se non è se non alleni mente
c'è bisogno di utilizzare gli strumenti
che abbiamo per farci aiutare e hutch e
come come far diventare un acceleratore
la nostra mente per farci aiutare dove
vogliamo andare di base che tanto mente
quando gli capita non date le troppo
retta quando vidi ci si detrae e vi tira
indietro da alcune situazioni e ancora
il coraggio attiva la trasformazione
per me coraggio è agire con il cuore per
fare qualcosa di bene per me di ben e
per gli altri che magari non è scontato
e ognuno di voi avrà un significato per
questo ma di fatto il coraggio attiva la
trasformazione e se ci vogliamo
trasformare come persone come imprese
come organizzazioni dobbiamo oggi più
che mai avere coraggio
certo non basta dobbiamo fare l'azione
perché sono le azioni che ti porta la
destinazione da sola non basta il
coraggio e ancora diciamo relazione ti
fa raggiungere la destinazione è ancora
identifica il tuo gruppo dei pari io
l'ho scelto così se vi piace lo potete
copiare persone migliori di me a fare
qualcosa e mi occupo di contribuire al
loro successo così sono sicuro che loro
si occupano di contribuire al mio e
diventa reciproco
infine porta sempre tue radici con te io
le ho portate qui e sono orgoglioso di
vedere qui è felicissimo di poter dare
alla mia famiglia questo territorio
questo è questo benessere che ci si
respira qui che diamo troppo per
scontato
e se siete d'accordo
gli farei fare un esercizio se no che
coach sarebbe giusto siete con me
ok liberate le mani mani libere
al mio tre vi chiedo di unire le mani in
questo modo e di tenerle unite 12 prec
chi di voi ha il pollice della mano
destra sopra alzi la mano
ok
chi di voi tenete riunite al pollice
della mano sinistra anzi la mano o mamma
mia quanti sinistro ma siete sicuri di
guardare bene ma sapete cosa vuol dire
io sono preoccupato
no scherza non vuol dire nibile è uno
schema motorio c'è un voyeur niente del
sinistra è un'abitudine motore va bene
così di nuovo però la cosa interessante
ora
da questa posizione
invertite la mano che sta sopra al mio
312 trek
come è stato
strano difficile sfidante o chi altro
lieber la mano però tutto questo è stato
state come ancora aprite chiudete le
mani dieci volte consecutivamente nella
nuova posizione 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
fermi di 11 11
come l undicesima rispetto alla prima
meglio molto meglio magari non come la
mano iniziale originaria giusto o meglio
non ancora ecco questo schema ci fa
capire delle cose molto interessanti
la prima ognuno di noi ha degli schemi
abituali
motori mentali e motivi comportamentali
di atteggiamento di processo
automatici e alle volte non ci rendiamo
conto che questi schemi a cui siamo
molto affezionati andavano bene un tempo
ma non più oggi rispetto dove stiamo
andando e ci frenano
quando lo scopriamo o qualcuno ce lo fa
scoprire perché chiediamo feedback a
qualcuno di questo iniziamo spostare il
comportamento e lì la calamai la nostra
mente cosa ci dice
mica tanto a giu
torniamo indietro facciamo come prima
anni che la mia frase preferita in
organizzazioni sapete qual è abbiamo
sempre fatto così
ed è quello che ti fa tornare indietro
ecco in quel momento la mente sta
mentendo
quand'è che invece prendete poi il
governo della mente quando iniziate ad
allenare un'abitudine un nuovo
comportamento che via ad andare nella
direzione che voi volete
e allora avete dei nuovi processi di una
mobilità dei nuovi atteggiamenti noi
strumenti personali organizzativi
aziendali che riportano dove volete e
magari dove meritate se decidete andarci
vi è piaciuto
detto ciò
che voi siate già nel vostro viaggio
ideale o che dobbiate è semplicemente
girare un po la rotta o fare una
strambata e andare da un altra direzione
ho da dirvi una cosa importante che mi
hanno detto
tanti anni fa
in viaggio tutto funziona
a voi buon viaggio
[Applauso]
[Musica]